he's not a good fellow i've never made
it there
how did you end up getting in touch with
robert de niro
well the cops that were on my case i
told you became their security guys
yeah and he was looking for somebody
from the old from the life that can
give him some tips on playing like a
a frank sharon type of guy a mob guy a
hitman or whatever
and they all said me and you know it and
it's funny too i i've said this a few
times it's it's
it's a double-edged sword they all said
me so i'm
gonna tell you how to kill a guy how to
get rid of weapons how to bury your body
i mean
that's what you would think but he also
wanted to get the
the verbiage the words the the uh
how and and situations how would this
happen how would a guy
knowing he's in trouble not run
not just run when you reach into your
pocket or you know and things like that
so because
there's a scene there where he's got to
kill a guy and uh
the guy knows he's in trouble so so i
told him how greg did it greg used to
have a handkerchief and he would sneeze
or cough and he'd reach his pocket
and the guy would see the handkerchief
come out and he'd actually be relieved
so he'd wipe his nose
when he put the hanky back in he comes
out with the gun
so that was a little trick of his yeah
psychological yeah i
i told him how we got rid of weapons and
all of that's in the movie i mean
so probably a dozen things that i sat
and talked to him about so what was like
a one-time meeting
no i i was with him probably three or
four times where did you guys meet like
what did you guys get well we met at
he has a hotel in greenwich village yeah
and his office is right there
okay so the first time i spent about
three hours with him and he was just
listening to me
and i kept saying mr d you want to say
something i mean you know no no keep
going keep going i was just listening
and getting words and hearing about hits
and from my book
uh then the next time he gave one of the
cops
a list of things and i got on the phone
with him then another time
we went back and we sat in his living
room uh
we went to scorsese's house one time and
really yeah yep and he had uh he wanted
me to meet martin scorsese
and he had uh uh two
casting directors there who were also
listening to me
so they were all for
using it for their own casting reasons
you know uh and ultimately i i was going
to get a part i didn't know what and it
might be the small part where i killed
albert anastasia in the barber seat
uh which was a famous or infamous hit in
new york
back in the 50s so it was it was
incredible experience
and then uh probably a month or so later
i'm in nick pillagie's house and
nicolegi wrote goodfellas casino
uh part of american gangster yeah he's
he's uh
the the three of them uh you know my
wife was with me throughout the whole
thing
we said we are sitting with cinematic
royalty that's what it is
it was amazing and uh and then i i met
him twice after as a matter of fact the
last day i got a picture i could show
you the last day of
filming he invited us in to watch the
last scene it was him
he was filming just you know uh a small
scene
just if when you see the movie you'll
see that he has to put a lock on
on a truck and there's significance to
that but it was funny
he made it he he tied a knot two
different ways and scorsese caught it
he says bob earlier on you tied a
different knot
so he had to tie it the same exact way
so the neighbor went like this to him
but that's right i mean and he went back
and he had to do the scene again you
know
and uh yeah it's crazy you think about
all like the little continuity details
like that when you're making a movie
yeah
everything has to because in case you
gotta kelly got to watch him film my c
through the camera he still uses the
old-fashioned cameras a lot of guys use
these new
things handhelds and stuff he uses the
old the big one that rolls film cameras
yeah the old
just uh yeah and she was able to look
through it and watch
exactly what he saw so they would come
and we did
my scene when you see it it's really
short but
it's probably 20 seconds
we filmed it 40 times really once he got
too much of a brick wall and he said
people aren't coming to the movies to
see a brick wall
he always got it's always then another
time one of the girls walking by me
smiled and he says what are you smiling
about what do you think you're in a
movie
she was walking a baby so she couldn't
smile
anyway yeah so what was it like going
into martin scorsese's house
what where was his house okay it's near
central park
in manhattan very expensive house it's
it's a four-story
uh brownstone those are very very rich
houses yeah very very what do you mean
what does that mean
it's a it's a type of house it's
they're they're all built together side
by side is it like on the ground level
there's a ground level okay then there's
four stories
but each one is your house it's they're
huge
so we go in a butler opens the door is
it kind of like what
i don't know if you've ever seen the
pictures of jeffrey epstein's house
in new york probably it's like between
these big buildings and just going it
looks like a cathedral
yeah no this no this i i know what
you're talking about uh
it's more how would you describe it kel
can you find it on google yeah yeah
katie could you find a picture of a
brownstone house in new york yeah
so anyway his was white yeah and it's
four stories we walk in
i don't know i'm going to his house i'm
i know i'm meeting him but i'm assuming
we're going to go to a restaurant or a
studio or something
so he brings us upstairs the butler to
like the third floor
and it's one huge living room
okay there was another room the other
way it might have been a bedroom but
so we're sitting down all of a sudden i
i just started walking around
and she's kelly's telling me sit down
you can't be walking around you know
where you're at you're just looking
around at [ __ ] so i go i see the oscars
he has it
oh no i'm looking at the oscars this is
marty's house martin scorsese's house
so i i turn around who's standing in the
door daenerys
so he comes over he says says hello sits
down then marty comes down with the two
girls
and it was uh it was it was amazing we
were talking and it was
you know a couple of times i i cursed
and i i apologized
because i don't like the curse i don't
you know uh
anyway it's another story but um
and i would say i'm sorry excuse me one
of the okay yeah yeah yeah yeah those
are all over new york
yeah and there you have my glasses on
for the distance yeah exactly
so you see the red one in the middle
there that one yeah but it was it was
like that but a white one it was a white
one
okay okay you might have zeroed in on
his house who knows it like it just
blends in with the rest of the
houses you can't even tell it's exactly
but inside
they're incredible and uh you know
they're very they're very uh expensive i
mean
very expensive nick pileggi and those
stu has those like stairways that just
go right to the sidewalk
yes every single one there's a basement
there's a floor level also
oh okay yeah so it's a it's a style from
back then
but yeah those are cool looking yeah
nick nick when we went to see nick
bledgey
he had uh we went on the second floor
and there was nothing but books
when he came in he came from upstairs
down
he says uh my wife made me buy this unit
also for my books
he lives in the penthouse and that
downstairs was sort of his office his
reading his library
yeah amazing but he had a big spread of
food out for us
and never forget it he says my mother
would never forgive me
if i didn't put out food for guests
amazing he's he's a very nice guy nick
very nice i could
i call him he always answers back uh
who's scorsese no uh oh nick pelagic
yeah yeah you know at the beginning i
was in contact a lot with dinero but he
wound up with
uh personal issues with going through
divorce and yeah and i think other thing
now with the pandemic
he's got businesses all over new york
that got to be getting killed
his restaurants his hotels so uh he's
sort of just been
i think he's in seclusion almost you
know
uh i i haven't uh talked to again
uh but you know he when we were leaving
he made us come back in because his wife
wanted to meet us
so we went back in and we met her and
then at the final day
of filming she was there and she has i
believe parkinson's
i think that's what it is uh
so she's having a little trouble but she
remembered us all these months later
she's
very you know so down and he's a nice
guy he was very personable like de
niro's quiet
yeah shy yeah scorsese talks he laughs
about you know he's outgoing you know
they're almost opposites that's so funny
man yeah yeah and uh the other thing i
learned is that
these casting directors
you don't have to be the greatest actor
okay because if you see if you start
watching
a lot of de niro's movies his
idiosyncrasies
are always there he you know most of his
movies
the way he laughs the way he look at you
you know
so when they're casting somebody they're
looking for certain things
you know like uh
not that he's not a great actor i mean
because he's done things like i saw out
of character like the deer hunter and
cape fear
those were fabulous i mean fantastic the
gangster movies to me
you know he's got like some fascination
with gangster
yeah well it's been a huge moneymaker
it's a huge moneymaker so
you know uh but
uh you know and then there's guys that
can you know go back on stage and play
hamlet you know
right you know but those you know those
uh
but anyway i i've noticed that that's
why you see a lot of the same guys in
the same movies
not because they're great there's just
because they almost don't have to act
like in the sopranos yeah it's almost
like he's got like that brand built
around himself where it's like you know
you just want this guy in your movie
because it makes it marketable you know
right
oh yeah no definitely no he's a brand
without a doubt you know he's in a movie
he's
gonna sell so well he's still maybe in
mine
you